what is going on everybody in welcome to
Charles 2.00 if you're not familiar with
the self-driving car project that we've
been working on basically it started off
with using open CV just to do like Lane
detection and stuff and then graduated
to doing deep learning and just seeing
how far we could take this absurd
project so eventually I got kind of
burnt out on it there was just so much
expectation that this AI was going to
somehow become like a really good
self-driving car and somehow like this
one guy in his you know room on his home
computer was going to outperform
multi-billion dollar companies at the
same task so anyway I kind of slowed
down on the development there but
recently I started to rethink the entire
project and like ouch and upload to your
Tesla now and and how I would revisit it
today because a lot of things have
changed since I really worked on this
project one being just my own
understanding of AI I'm gonna probably
have to help him out of this situation
let me just get him out of here real
quick in my own understanding of AI and
machine learning and training models and
validating models but then also just the
field has changed quite a bit so the
original model well the last model was
he's just totally screwed at this point
let me get him out of here I'm just
gonna teleport a couple of times
let's do
trying to get back into like the city or
something area it's a little more
interesting more things to avoid unless
places to fall off although I'm not sure
we're in the city I guess we are anyway
so models have also changed so the how
we got we're screwed now oh hopefully
let's see if he'll get himself out of
this one nice actually did I thought I
was gonna have to save him
so models have changed let's try that
try to talk about those changed models
now keep driving Charles so the last
model was inception v3 which is actually
kind of an old model now you know
there's an inception before resin and
mobile net and currently we're running
exception which seems to be pretty good
but some of the other major mistakes
that I had made or like so with like
validation data for example the way I
had been doing validation data was I
pulled like I would shuffle the data and
then I pulled randomly data out of that
shuffle data and called that validation
data well the problem is this is
inherently like sequential types of data
so when you shuffle and then pull
randomly your validation data is going
to very closely match in sample data so
any over fitment is going to kind of
pour over into your out-of-sample or we
know no we're not wanted right now so
one of the things about this model is
one he knows how to reverse like he just
did and he also goes between cars and
stuff which is super cool polls will
still screw him every time he just can't
figure pulls out some I'm fixing him at
the moment while we're at it let me
let's see let's change let's go forward
in some time here and let me remove the
Waypoint let's see how he does with the
X the other model was really really bad
and if it didn't have the GPS route
okay so I've unpause dit and we'll see
how he does so as you can see he's not a
complete idiot he'll still do things
like u-turn and then you turn again
which doesn't make much sense or he'll
get stuck in like parking lots and stuff
that look like roads and then he's like
I don't have to do here but for the most
part he does pretty darn good
also he tends to avoid accidents and
like weaves between cars and stuff way
better than any other model so right
break here kind of a random turn but
really sure why he's doing that
but regardless can drive without the
waypoints so the reason why that's
important is it tells me that the AI is
not just looking at that tiny square in
the corner whereas the last model was
really I think hyper focused on that
square
you know just watching that Purple Line
so anyway I like that this is a little
more intelligent he might get stuck here
see if he gets out no I got out I think
that was pure luck though so anyways the
model out-of-sample data is much
different first poll and then image
scaling so the other thing I never
really did our image normalization was
let's give him something a little more
interesting here I'm gonna pause it and
let's give him some police nope wrong
thing to click there what's going on why
is it going back to zero what did that
just happen
I almost wonder if I hit never wanted
somewhere it's almost like it's turning
it off oh I think it's cuz we have a mod
shoot this will be this is gonna cause
trouble so we've been running the stream
yeah okay so I've got to reload the game
the reason why is so we've got the
twitch stream and there's a chat
integration so you can talk with do this
or figure out the commands with commands
but basically you can do things like
change cars or bring in police and all
kinds of stuff
and the problem is police are turned off
in that mod so it's kind of fighting in
games so what I'm gonna do here is turn
on the police and so we can show the
police so please set on ok so now we
have police allowed and then what I can
do is give them some stars so you can
see how he does with police and without
waypoints that'll be interesting let me
move the mouse out of the way my
apologies for the screen shaking ok so
what all has changed let's see so I
think we were talking about image
scaling the the problem that I was
having was I just didn't personally
understand like why why you would need
to scale the images between like 0 and 1
when there every pixel was on the same
scale right 0 to 255 so why scale
between 0 1
he just didn't didn't click so I didn't
do it I thought it was stupid
plus I felt like it was working fine so
why do it
and he's driving pretty well usually he
doesn't drive as well with the waypoints
off but he's doing pretty good for the
fact that he's trying to avoid so many
police cars and stuff I know any second
now he's gonna crash into a pole right
yeah so ok so so yeah so new models
validation data and the other thing is
the weights so when the model is done
training if you've if you'd watch the
previous you know GT a self-driving car
series I apply one more set of weights
to the output layer well
the way I derived those weights was just
manually I just kind of tweaked them
watched it in game tweaked him again
watched him in game we're gonna thread
that needle and smash that car so he's
he's like he's so good sometimes and
then other times he's like not good but
man he's actually driving real there we
go there's the tree I knew it man he's
driving oh there's drew okay so wow he's
actually he might get himself out of
this I don't know
he sometimes he does reverse but if
nothing's changing in the picture you
can't really expect him to do anything
else
ooh we might get a water charles here
any second now there's there's a river
right in front of him i kind of want to
help him but i also want to see if he's
gonna wind up in the water
i'm gonna help him out actually the mod
will probably help him out in a second
and I'll teleport him away from here I'm
just gonna pause it though and move him
on pause and we're off hopefully go
Charles I go a bump then he actually
seems to really want that water
okay i'm gonna teleport him out of here
he was doing so good and those are like
situations where the waypoint really
helps like he gets lost and then if
there's a waypoint i think it helps for
the AI to understand like okay I'm off
like I don't know where I'm off but if I
look at this purple line I can see how
to get back on track and so the Waypoint
really seems to help in those situations
um anyway back to the output layer
weights I would just kind of manually do
those and that was just kind of
problematic so let me let me pause this
real quick and I'm gonna go to time and
let's go to nighttime I'm gonna fix him
here out of the way okay so now we're at
nighttime let's see how well he does
with police no Waypoint and nighttime
previous Charles was very scared at
night especially of his headlights you
would see the headlights and be like ah
there you go please go
don't make me reset you again
one of these are gonna keep turning in
circles here go Charles I'm showing you
to the world okay so so with the output
layer weights I was just doing those
manually and so I started to try to
think about like okay well how can we
make this better like because this is a
hard challenge so then the next thing I
started to work on was a closeness score
where I said hey W isn't as like W if
the correct prediction was let's say W
plus D right if that was the correct
British prediction so let's say let's
say the correct prediction is is you
know forward you know gasps and turn
right and all he chose was turn right
well that's wrong but it's less wrong
than turn left right and so so I started
to think about like well how can i how
can we fix this so then I started to do
it like a closeness score where even if
he got it wrong but if he was close to
some degree it was worth you know a
quarter of a percent correct right so
it's like it's 75% wrong but 25% right
at least so I did something like that to
help me tweak the weights and I started
to think about well there's got to be
even a better way and so the theory is
that the sort of the validation set is a
perfectly balanced in terms of all
predictions validation set so then I
started to feel like well if that's true
and we know that's true then the the
results from the validation data should
be perfectly balanced
so therefore what if I wrote a script
that you know ran the validation test
set and then adjusted weights such that
it would balance all of the outputs let
me pause this again and let's let's go
back to day time and then we'll turn off
the police and maybe I'll just do it via
the mod so I don't forget later
[Music]
please sets off so hopefully they'll
turn them away did I do it wrong it
doesn't look like please set off I'm
gonna have to do it myself manually or
something I'm not really sure why I
didn't turn him off their
work-in-progress everybody I'm just
gonna do that for now I'll have to
remember that okay and then I think I'm
gonna turn the waypoints back on I
mostly I just wanted to show you guys
that it does work without the waypoints
and I think it works pretty well
it just works a little better especially
when he gets lost to have some sort of
direction and then I'm gonna take him
back to the city I just think the city's
a little more interesting than like
driving in a straight line basically on
the freeway
um more things are crashing two more
things to avoid so anyways so then I
started to think about you know
balancing that dished out and you know
the output distribution and that works
pretty well so the thing that gets
predicted the most I just started to
decay that wait so each iteration I
would decay it just a tiny percent and
just keep doing that over and over and
over until the distribution was
relatively balanced and this is the
result it's it makes a huge difference
so that's pretty cool I don't you know
I'd never really considered doing that
but I bet that would work pretty well
with other machine learning models too
not just a self-driving car because you
know that that output layer or that the
the output should be evenly distributed
if your validation set is indeed
perfectly balanced so if you can adjust
those final weights to make that so that
really does seem to make a big
difference so I'm curious to try that on
other problems to see if it really does
help or if this was just like a unique
case where it did help so anyways that's
all for now hello tree wish we could
figure out the tree issue the training
data does have samples where I I would
like pull up to a tree
start the truck start the data
collection and then show reversing from
the trees so I mean I do have training
data that is involved with getting
itself away from cars walls trees and
sometimes you'll see it does work but
too often it doesn't so maybe more data
of it doing that would be helpful so
anyways that's all for now tutorials to
come on all the things I just talked
about I do have the training data I
don't know how I'm gonna share it with
people or if I'm gonna share it with
people it's a very large data set fully
compressed it's still six hundred four
hundred gigabytes so I'm not really sure
where I would put that or where I'm
gonna host it or maybe do like a torrent
or something like that possibly I really
don't know the model itself is like 200
megabytes so I may host that model and
then any pretty much anybody can run it
as long as you well anybody can try to
run it but you probably should have a
1080 Ti or better to run it right now
this is running on a paper space virtual
machine on a p6000 GPU so that has 24
gigabytes of vram so quite a bit of e
ram but i have run this locally on my
own computer and that's running at 1080
TI so it does work pretty well there in
the future what I'd like to do is add in
add back in object detection the
tensorflow object detection API one is
much better now two is highly updated
it's it since the time I used it so it's
I just couldn't even really probably use
it now and the code that I use to run
the object detection so we mostly use
the object detection nice-nice avoidance
there Charles Wiimote in this site this
poor soul too we mostly use object
detection to like steal cars or when I
was in the tank
I had Charles be able to like shoot the
tank which was pretty cool so I'd like
to bring stuff like that back and this
time around I'd really like to have a
good version of an on foot Charles that
you know so self-driving I know it's not
great in the status that it's in I mean
everything it better would be better but
this is pretty close to like to what I
would want this is your average three
ten-year-old GTA online player right
here maybe better so so I'm pretty
content now with the driving I would
like it to be better of course always
want to make stuff better but this is
pretty pretty darn good so I want to get
like an on foot version something that
you know can walk around can engage with
police and military and stuff like that
and just do more of playing Grand Theft
Auto flying would also be pretty cool
like the helicopters the Jets that kind
of stuff so we still have tons and tons
of plans I'm just gonna do my best to to
not get burnt out on this project so the
just the last time it's just the
expectations we're just way too high and
I think I'm just gonna try to take it a
little slower because this stuff just
takes it just takes so much work and so
much time and it just got to the point
where it wasn't really fun anymore
whereas this time around I actually had
a pretty good time like revamping this
whole thing and it was pretty cool to
see how big of an impact that made so
anyways definitely more to come
tutorials on all this stuff
all the changes that I made all that
kind of stuff like I said I may or may
not host the data ma'am and I host the
model I haven't really decided also the
stream is back it's not running 24/7 yet
I might start running it 24/7 not really
sure what I want to do there I'm not
sure I was a big fan of keeping it going
24/7 it also just costs a lot of
resources to keep it running 24/7 so not
really sure I'm going to do that might
come up with some sort of automated
schedule don't really know anyways I
just wanted to update you guys on where
I was with the project I was super
excited with this model I just think
it's so much better than the last
charles models so anyways that's all for
now questions comments whatever feel
free to leave them below otherwise look
at him thread that needle see you next
time oh can we also just take a moment
to appreciate that this is all running
on a paper space virtual machine
I'm sure there's like some compression
for you guys but to me this looks
identical to if I was like playing this
locally on my machine I just think it's
crazy and like I can play it and it
feels just like I'm playing it locally
man it's so hard to see these things at
night and I'm pretty sure I would have
crashed into the same stuff
anyways that's just nuts so for anybody
who's interested you can go to Python
programming at slash paper space to
learn more about paper space and I also
have a referral credit there that you
can use it's like a referral link so if
you want to check that out awesome
otherwise in this video is not sponsored
or anything by paper space it's just
that people have used those credits and
so I've been using paper space to do a
lot of my machine learning so they're
just like they're just high-end GPUs in
the cloud and they just so happen to
have like these virtual desktops so for
example I can minimize this and like you
can see like it's a full desktop like
it's a Windows 8 or now this actually
Windows 10 machine but they have like
Linux machines and all that - so anyways
that's all for now
till next time